[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Frances Foster i'm konstantine kissin
and this is the show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant guest today is a
youtuber Arielle Scarcella welcome to
trigonometry
how are you guys over there you pay yeah
we're we're locked down we are keeping
it a safe distance from each other but
before we get into all of that for
anyone who doesn't know who you I just
tell everybody who are you what has been
your journey through life that leads you
to being on trigonometry in this very
remote and some way how about
interesting I came out as a lesbian at
19 and that is why you're here that's
because a lot of your guy a lot of your
viewers are probably straight men who
love lesbians and you know what the
straight guys have been nothing but
gracious and really sweet to me so it's
like i joked a lot about like those
straight men but like literally I've
never had a problem with them personally
yeah but I came out when I was 19 I
started making content on YouTube about
being a lesbian when I was 23 and my
content has changed I wouldn't say
dramatically but politically it's
changed a little you know quite a bit
and it's it's it's gotten to the point
where I you know I I stir up some drama
and you know is this tea being spilled
but I think it's because I'm the one
open you know out lesbian on YouTube
that you know calls out [ __ ]
honestly that will call out the [ __ ]
of the progressive left or of the right
but like I've never had an issue with
the right so I haven't had to call
anybody out what's its religious people
that I'm just like it's not even worth
my time you know because they're allowed
to believe whatever the hell they
believe as long as they're not
infringing upon my rights fine
yeah and I I came out with a video about
two months ago about leaving the
progressive left I never officially came
out as conservative because I don't
think I'm fully conservative I think I'm
like somewhere in the middle and I've
I've
yeah a lot of a lot of more conservative
or right-wing channels or even
libertarian channels have been asking
for my opinions on LGBT topics because I
feel like I'm kind of an expert at this
point a few weeks ago a lot of our fans
started clamoring for us to talk to you
and I think your your YouTube channel
has been completely demonetised is that
right it was up until like yesterday it
was it was demonetized for five weeks
yeah they remonda ties me but I had to
change a whole bunch of stuff like
unfortunately yeah they and it's funny
because a lot of people were like I
really making the same content literally
for ten years and apparently they D
monetize me for having sexually explicit
content I've been posting the same type
of videos for ten years so how come as
soon as I came out as non progressive
all of a sudden it's just like and and
again like people rally behind me and
and I'd like the few no the progressive
the progressive I'll just call them the
woke left from now I'm just so you guys
cuz I want to keep saying progressive
it's annoying but the woke you know the
world left likes to hate on this
straight heterosexual white men dead of
it and it's like the people that
actually donated to my patreon or sis
straight white white white med nine out
of ten times it was those types of
people that were being supportive so I
think a lot of these people are
misunderstood I think I think the far
left you know finds it easier these days
to just hate on somebody for who they
are not what they believe you know like
oh you're well you're a man you can't
you don't have a say oh you're that
you're this you don't have to say oh
you're your sis you can't you can't talk
on trans topics and it's like why can't
everybody talk about every topic and if
it affects them in some way you know I'm
saying like if I'm not gonna talk about
like gay men issues I have no it doesn't
affect me in any sense of the word but
trans issues do affect everybody because
it's changing the definitions of the
word man and woman that affects
everybody love it I think everybody
should have a part of the conversation
you know and I don't think I don't think
I've seen that many people that are
actually hateful about it
they're just cautious or curious
or worried I haven't seen that many
hateful people personally and REO so you
touched on the whole trans issue now
I've got a couple of mates who are gay
women and they are to use how can I put
this correct terminology absolutely
[ __ ] livid what is happening in
particular what is happening to women's
spaces can you touch on particularly why
is this such an emotive subject for you
and why is it so important for you well
first of all there's it's gotten to the
point where even this week is lesbian
visibility week and I think it's diva
magazine which is in the UK it's like
the one lesbian magazine over there I
think
so it's like two lesbian AGA's eenz in
the whole world and that's what I'm and
he's really very like underrepresented
underrepresented community right the
trans depends on do I have to say that's
true right I know are we allowed to
curse like it when you talk when you be
at porn I mean lesbian portance one of
the most watched right well yeah it's
gotten to the point where I was just
having a conversation with my friend
Mars who's a trans guy and we were
talking about the lesbian visibility
week it's I mean it's a made-up holiday
like we I did a whole series of videos
years ago when people believe me I would
just make up fake LGBT holidays and
people were like yeah let's celebrate
I'm like I just made this up it's a
made-up holiday for it has good
intentions obviously right lesbian
visibility we but they have you know a
trans woman and I'm not saying trans
women can't be socially lesbians right
but the person that they're featuring
has only been out for a few years and
they're in their 50s like you live the
majority of your life as a heterosexual
man
maybe we shouldn't you know take the one
week or the one day I think which is
actually tomorrow I might be the 26th
lesbian visibility day officially might
be the 26th why are we constantly prop
you know propping up trans women that
identify as lesbians and not females you
know like it should it I don't I don't
know how to explain this but it's like
I'd never people call me transphobic for
for saying
women can't be lesbians I've never
actually said that because I think there
is a social aspect to to gayness right
like if you appear yeah like like you
know what like drag queen goes out in
public and passes as a woman
she's not gonna experience homophobia
you know what I mean like in that moment
so there is a cultural aspect to it so
even if you identify as a woman gender
wise in your brain whatever that means
right there has been proof that that
trans women have there's a part of their
brain that looks it looks more similar
to somebody like myself you're not going
to know what it's like to live and be
seen as a woman until you stop looking
like a man like that's just how it is
you know II mean like that's unfortunate
but you can't see in somebody's inside
somebody's brain and it's impossible to
know how somebody identifies and so you
ask them and even then most the time
people like because they're ashamed
which is also [ __ ] but yeah like the
taking over female space is it's a real
thing that's happening and a lot of
people are like oh that doesn't even
happen that often I don't care if it
happens one time it's something you need
to talk about because if it happens one
time and people think it's okay it's
gonna come it's gonna happen more and
more and more and more you know from
from trans women you know what the funny
thing is it's not even that many actual
trans women it's most of these very
young very hip woke queer kids you know
that that are somewhere like in the end
we hold them the alphabet people they're
probably not even LGBTQ they're like
they're like queer or like non-binary or
some other made-up gender and they're
like trans women are wait I mean if you
don't want to suck a dick you know
you're you're you're you're trans folk
you're transphobic a horrible person you
know and these are look like literally
you can go on tumblr you can go in
Twitter you can Instagram this is these
are real thing like turf is a slur go on
that website turf is a slur calm people
like that's a transfer website no it's
not that it's a real thing and people
just documenting what people are saying
what you know queer activists are saying
to two lesbians and it's just now
starting to make its way into the gay
community but it doesn't happen nearly
as often because gay men are men right
mm-hmm a real one thing I've not just as
well as with I've spoken to a few of my
friends who are gay
and one of the things they've said and
that makes them very concerned about
some of the stuff around the trans issue
is that they feel like because a lot of
them were gender non-conforming as
children they may well have ended up
being categorized and encouraged into
being trans well simply because they
were gay kids do you think that's a big
part of the issue 100% i I think that
there I think there was an article
written I mentioned it last year in one
of my videos I had with my friend Blake
who is legitimately I my opinion trans
guy he has gender dysphoria he had Top
surgery he's transitioned in every way
that he can you have a lot of trans
trans friends for a bigot I have to say
I know
well rational trans people but you know
but obviously they're just tokens and
they're the wrong type of trans because
they agree with me but um yeah most of
the trans people if not all of them and
I'm friends with or irrational and you
know very sweet and and they're just
like I want to live my [ __ ] life like
it sucks that I had to live this that I
had to experience this but now I'm you
know I'm transitioned in whatever way
that I can and I mean yeah my friend my
friend Blake and I did a video last year
where we talked about the think of the
increase in the amount of people ID any
amount of females identifying as trans
in some way has like quadrupled over the
last few years especially in the UK
because the UK is even more progressive
progressive then because it's not even
progressive in my opinion but
progressive than the Fen the states and
I it was also there was also a study I
want to say was the HRC Human Rights
Campaign which is based here I think it
might it might be a worldwide but it's I
think it's actually based in DC where
like every year they they're mentioning
trans and non-binary identities in queer
more and more and they're like yearly
reports and the word lesbian wasn't even
mentioned in the last two years or
something and it makes us feel it makes
young lesbians that are you know gender
non-conforming which technically are
lesbians or gender non-conforming if you
really
about it right because we're not
conforming to the expectation that we're
supposed to date men so when you go when
you dive into things and look at them on
a deeper level you know it's it's quite
easy to see how a young lesbian or a
young gay boy would think that they're
trans and this is happening more and
more even on YouTube there are people
that are coming out more and more as D
transitioners and realizing that they
did not have gender dysphoria and they
just hated their bodies maybe they had
dysmorphia or maybe they just were going
through teenage [ __ ] I did that I I
hated my body for a long time because I
wasn't feminine enough but then doesn't
mean that being trans isn't real like it
is clearly a real disorder like it's a
real whatever you want to call it a
disorder of you know a brain body
disconnect or something it's a real
thing but because of the because the
word trans has been watered down to
literally mean absolutely nothing but an
identity kids are very vulnerable teens
are very vulnerable and they most them
just want to fit in
they're already you know some of them
are already bullied or just feel
ostracized in their community for
whatever reason and they're like well
everyone knows else is coming out as
trans and they're being accepted and
they're being loved and why don't I do
that and it's it's not the case 100% in
time of course but it's happening more
and more
choose me more and more and if there's
something to the reason I'm talk about
it is because it is happening more often
than not to people that are that are
female and I think that says a lot too
no it's it's happened to my former
colleague and a friend her daughter
recently came out a 12 year old girl a
12 year old girl came out and told her
mother my friend were when I transition
not if when and at the age of 12 years
old and is part of the reason that we
think oh you're they're going to
transition they don't realize the
medical implication that this is having
on your body and the fact is that you
were going to become a medical patient
for the rest of your life if you're a
trans person right which which is
unfortunate in itself I wish I wish
there was like a sis pal
trans people will tell you that to like
a true a true trans binary trans person
right well we'll tell you like if there
was a Sisko I would take it tomorrow
and I can of course I can't imagine what
that would feel like it's it's
completely not even similar to being a
LGB at all feeling like you're born in
the wrong body or feeling like your body
is in some way wrong yeah you wouldn't
wish it on anyone I mean we kind of
sometimes people on our show talking to
them about it and when they describe it
you know it's not something you would
wish on your worst enemy because it's
not yeah not a pleasant experience but
let me ask you this because one of the
stats that we came out recently is that
acceptance of sexual minorities and
trans people I included it and I even
love not with a sexual minority but
anyway has actually gone down quite
significantly which is an incredible I
mean you'd have to work really hard in
the 21st century to get people to be
less tolerant I'd have I know this is
down to well maybe it's because you know
in the UK there are things like people
punching you know woke them woke people
on the walk left they're punching 60
year-old women for going into a [ __ ]
basement in a library to talk about
women's rights it's like and there's
spray in Vancouver they're
spray-painting rape you know rape crisis
centers saying that only females or have
you not heard of this was a rape relief
center in Vancouver that was
spray-painted with turf and bigoted not
these people because they wouldn't
accept because they wouldn't women right
well yeah because it's because it's
probably not the right place for them
right you know I mean like if they were
raped I don't you know I don't even know
I mean there are a lot of trans women
that get raped yes I don't know if if
they still belong like to me if I was I
don't even know I've never been raped
but I'm assuming if I had just been
raped I would not want to see somebody
with a penis next to me personally and
and it's not that it's not again it's
not like it's not a bigoted saying it's
not has nothing dude person being trans
it has to do with worrying about the
person that had just been raped so if
there's a way that they can
fix that you know that maybe there's a
way but people have to understand that
it's it's not just like no we hate trans
people it's like no we care about this
female right you might be triggered by
that held the friggin trans woman alone
is probably triggered by her own penis
like most of the time you don't even
look they don't want it there so I think
hopefully I like you would think they
would understand it a lot of them do
that's the thing it's these it's these
radical queer extremists that I usually
talk about my videos it's not it's
usually not binary
you know rational trans people it's it's
these crazy extremists that want to
break binaries you know which is funny
because that's actually not helping
trans people at all because trans people
want to go from one to the other right
they don't want it they want to exist
within the binary they don't want to
break it and a lot of them I also notice
there's a ton of I have a video about
this coming out soon hopefully but I
mean it's gonna take me a little while
to do some research but there's an
influx of sis straight white men gamers
on YouTube that have been posting like
hateful content about me and other like
turfs and I it makes me think you know I
I just I sit there and I wonder why
these people think that they are allowed
to speak on issues again that don't
affect them if you're a dude and you
look like you and you look like you know
Francis and you're just walking around
and you know somebody like me comes into
your bathroom you I mean you're gonna be
like okay like what the hell are you
doing here but you're not gonna feel
threatened you know to me you're not
gonna get like you know it's a very
different experience living as a man hi
guys and welcome to my bedroom or is
this otherwise called Palacio orgasmic
now this is a short video on behalf of
the angel comedy club now you may not be
aware but there is something on the
planet right now called the corona Horus
which is putting a little bit of a
spanner into the works of a lot of
people especially comedy clubs in
particular angel comedy club which is
where we film our show and angel been so
supportive to us they've been absolutely
brilliant and when they now need
your help because they can't have any
shows they can't run a bar but the
problem is they still have to pay rent
so if you think a comedy club which puts
on acts like Stuart Lee Eddie is on
Maria Bamford for a fiver and lets us
film for free is something that should
exist in the world I personally think it
should then all you have to do is give a
little bit of money to the patron or
maybe become a patron yourself or put in
a little bit of money to the PayPal
account I will have links there'll be
links at the bottom in order for you to
do that now if you can't do that no
worries at all we completely understand
but hopefully you'll be able to maybe
pop down to Angel one day to see a live
show from us or a whole host of other
fabulous comedians stay safe and take
care I really want to sort of explore
this idea of women's save spaces because
I don't think men get it they just don't
they they go I can't see what women are
complaining about surely it's fine I've
done and you use the example used but
isn't part of it the fact that women on
the whole tend to be physically weaker
than men which means that therefore you
are more vulnerable so I always use the
example of a nightclub where if a man
chats to a woman and a woman feels that
she's uncomfortable with the situation
the one safe space that she has in order
to get rid of the dude is to go and walk
into the women's toilets he can't follow
her she says that's very true yeah and
if we remove that all of a sudden that
safe space is gone that's true yeah
that's that's what it's come to
I've been in a nightclub where was I in
Savannah Georgia it was an LGBT
nightclub and there was this I mean he
was he was good-looking but like
obviously not my type it's like very
handsome tall black you seemingly so
straight man and he comes up and starts
talking to me and I'm like dude you're
at a [ __ ] gay bar like what are you
doing you don't even like people just
they just don't get it sometimes so it's
just to have somebody that looks male
there was a really fun I'll give an
example there's a really funny tweet
that somebody posted it's a parody
account and I think it's somebody was
like how can we he was responding to
somebody and the tweet that he was
respond
- said something like how can we tell
you know how can we deal with the trans
women's bathroom issue and because of it
and he's like well we should just he was
being like control that he was like I
should say she cuz they identify as a
trans woman but like I have a beard
never it's a troll account I don't even
know if the dude is real but um she
responded with we should have a button
two buttons outside of a women's toilets
or any safe space for women one that
says yes I'm legitimately a trans woman
and what once was and then you press
that one you go and one that says no I'm
taking advantage of this situation and
it's true it's like how could you really
know it doesn't it's not like it's not
like we're saying trans women have no
women experience some of them do someone
that legitimately live live their lives
as women for a very long time but what
happened like the whole idea of
self-identification is what a lot of
women are saying no - these are people
that look like you that can just call
themselves women and expect to be
treated as such when it's like you have
no idea what it's like in my opinion you
might like okay in your own head
whatever whatever that means but if you
went into a woman's face and didn't see
to me that you know then you're not a
real woman at all like if you it most
women and I might be a nurture versus
nature think it might be very much a
nurture thing if you are truly a woman
like you say you are and you go into a
space and you're not aware of how you're
making other people around you feel
you're not a woman because women are
taught to be that way right since since
I was very young as a kid you are taught
to pay attention to how your actions and
how your even how your thoughts can make
other people feel that doesn't mean that
men aren't like you know that men also
don't go through [ __ ] I'm not saying
that but there are different privileges
living as a man and living as a woman
that neither sex will understand until
they live is that you know no absolutely
absolutely those that there's you know
about you know the different what it's
like to be a woman there's so for
instance my girlfriend I helped to I'm a
comedian to help to on a comedy club and
at the end of the show we were letting
people out and somebody felt a bit ill
so I had to sort of go and help man the
door get people out bring people in and
my girlfriend came and stood right next
to me and I'm like do you have to do
this now is this the right moment to do
this and she went I'm sorry I've got no
choice there was a dude following me
around the bar and he was really
freaking me out but nothing ever
happened to me as a man never it could
but it's unlikely
yeah it's unlikely but that's something
that I never have to worry about that
I'm never concerned about and I think
that's part of the problem is that men
seed we see the world through our eyes
and somewhere women come out and go look
there's this issue we go well it's not a
problem for me so why don't you just
grow up yeah and then and then I think
again with the lot of these work gamer
Bros you know I think they the funny the
funny thing is and why I think this is
happening I'm not a hundred percent sure
yet there's there's a there's like at
least 10 or 15 of them now that are
better just I think it's you know that
they I think they want to see woke
because it's cool to be woke these days
which is not actually woke at all in my
opinion but I also think that they feel
guilty before being assist straight and
white like I really do I really do and
I'm an i it's it's a weird thing it's it
you know it's it's like the only way to
please the far-left if you are a
straight white male is to be like I know
that I'm privileged I know that I miss I
know that I met I know that I'm not and
everybody else is at Turf and
everybody's transphobic and everyone's
raised it's like and that's what these
guys are doing like every single one of
them so it just makes me question is
this what they really believe or are
they guilt like are they do they feel
guilty for being privileged or do they
just want a left-wing audience for
whatever reason because most of this
[ __ ] that they say is it woke like in
any sense of the word because first of
all they're speaking over trans people
and speaking over female well if these
guys
watching I just like to say guys stop it
just enjoy your privilege as a straight
white man it's not gonna last for them
very much just enjoy it guilty about it
just be the straight white man patient
yeah they say you shouldn't feel guilty
about about how you how you live through
the world what you should do is be aware
of how others have to go through it yeah
right that's there's a big difference
but talk to me about the YouTube thing
because you said you had to make changes
what does that mean exactly you have to
make changes in order to get your
channel romana ties I had to just change
the the wording in some of the videos
like the titles and the thumbnails of
the more controversial topics I don't
know if that's actually what helped me
like that they don't tell you like why
the channels D monetize they just tell
you it's they just say you know it it's
very vague I don't know how to actually
say what they said cuz I don't member
but it's it's not like this video it has
this wrong with it like they don't have
time to do that they're just like okay
this channels annoying me somebody
complained about it probably I don't
know how it works and they're like fix
some [ __ ] and then we'll get back to you
it was really like what it comes down to
so I just I think it was like 15 20
videos some of them I private it or
deleted some of them some of them were
just like sexually explicit but like not
even cuz their sexual education and I
again I've been posting that kind of
concept for 10 years so why now all of a
sudden is there something wrong with it
you know so I don't know if it's
actually YouTube that had an issue with
it or if it was just a whole bunch of
people you know spamming my channel at
once that had a problem like I really
there's no way for me to know I just I
just know that I had to my even my
network they were like well we'll give
you some tips and you know I guess what
I'm getting at is do you think that if
you were making content about you know
I'm a you know trans woman with a penis
he is the best way to suck my dick do
you think that would be can I just say
we're gonna clip that and I'm gonna make
that go viral could ya
saying exactly I'm finally coming out as
my true self Frances and you know what
we could do we could put a little beat
behind it and turn it into one of those
little dance anthems exactly that'd be
brilliant but but do you think of what I
guess what I'm a serious point is what
I'm getting at is if you were making
content that was very woke and
progressive and you were you know coming
at it from that angle and it was sexual
in nature some of your videos definitely
have been always from way back when
yeah do you think that you would have
had the same experience
um I there's no way for me to tell like
for sure I will say that since I started
becoming less of a progressive I stopped
being invited to YouTube events I will
say that but I also know that the two
people that are like really cool with
YouTube that are part of the LGBT
community hate me that are like you know
involved in the YouTube side of LGBT
community like they actually have like a
connection with YouTube or contact the
YouTube one of them deals with the LGBT
part of VidCon and they despise me so I
wouldn't be I wasn't surprised that I
like wasn't invited to VidCon even
though I didn't want to go back anyway
because it was always during Pride so
that just kind of would sucked if I
couldn't go to my own Pride Parade
but also just because VidCon itself has
had become super super super
progressively woke you know and you
can't like me it's literally like VidCon
is the epitome of progressive YouTube
progressives on YouTube at least when I
went in 2016 I think what it was 2016
and it's unfortunate because they're not
allowing the weird part of it is they're
not allowing people that identify that
that are women that identifies women
that present as women that are female to
speak about their issues you know it's
only about the Q and the T at the moment
which mmm you know on the more serious
topics anyway of course they'll have
coming-out panels and stuff like that
like great
but yeah that I think there are more
serious issues that need to be addressed
and people like you know Rose of dawn
and Blair white and Sophia there's
there's a bunch of trans women that
navigate those issues very well in my
opinion and I take note of that and I'm
like I'm ten times more as women because
they are get so aware of how their lives
affect other women that's a woman but
and it's true when you think about it
right yeah the one thing that I really
wanted to talk to you about her how was
I see your journey and my journey has
been similar because I'm traditionally I
would have seen myself always as being
on the left I'm a former school teacher
works in twelve years you know
underprivileged kids you would go get
that's somebody on the left but more and
more I've just seen my own side go what
I called Tonto and I think I I can't I
can't be part of that what was the
moment for you where you thought you
know what I'm done I can't be part of
this anymore was there a specific moment
was it a gradual process it was a grad
like online it was gradual mm-hmm
I just started disagreeing like more and
more with people and realized how crazy
in my opinion that how irrational their
views were but what really solidified it
for me was and I said this in other
interviews I was I was going to Vegas
for to meet to front to Internet friends
of mine Tara Babcock who her name sounds
like a porn star but she's not and my
friend Paige who actually was a porn
star and we were gonna film you know
sex-positive videos and stuff like that
and Paige shuttered her own porn company
and Tyra he's an awesome youtuber and I
had never met either there in person and
Tara and I had just become friends so
she didn't really like know much about
me and then when we finally met in
person
she was like oh I saw you know I'm so
glad that you're that you're really
chill and that you're you know super
open-minded because when I saw your
Twitter profile it said like women
empowerment and it had a little gay
rainbow flag and I thought you were one
of those crazy people and I was like
okay like I can't even have a [ __ ]
rainbow flag in my bio anymore because
people associate that with crazies like
people need to know that I am NOT one of
them
people because I don't yeah I've refused
to be people that that are anti science
and anti logic and it just makes us all
it just makes us all look like lunatics
and I think that's the truth of why you
know the rate of LGBT acceptance is down
it's not actual lesbians and gays and
bisexuals it's the queer the radical
queer and trans activist again not even
binary trans people usually says they're
usually really cool like blair it's
everybody kind of in the middle you know
and especially young kids because they
are they have the most time on their
hands they're the loudest and they're
also the they haven't had the experience
yet so they think they [ __ ] know
everything Dargis of youth yeah yeah i
guess that's a way yeah they are get
they're very arrogant in in their in
their in their youth yeah an area do you
think that there is a danger like
because we all excuse most people are
sane reasonable rational you sit down
you talk with them you go okay i can see
we disagree but I get where you're
coming from I don't believe I understand
your reasons for believing it are we now
in this world where we get these very
very small minority of people who are
incredibly loud and we believe that is
your group when actually isn't there
just a couple of nutters on twitter who
because they're so loud they're so angry
they're so polarizing they get these
huge numbers following them so we think
that they're actually the important ones
and they're not they're just nutters yes
but yes I agree with you but that
doesn't mean that just because they're a
very small minority a very loud small
minority doesn't mean that they're
actually not making waves like they are
you know which is why otherwise I just
feel like okay they're just like
shouting out into the [ __ ] void
but situations like with Sydney Mardi
Gras I was invited out there well to
speak and these the crazies on Twitter
you know made a petition about me a
thousand people signed it nut meanwhile
none of these people actually came to
the event of course they don't ever come
to the event and they made it out to
seem to be for me to be
made it out as if I was this terrible
person and just my existence being in
Australia was triggering for them and I
but they but they got Sydney Mardi Gras
to take our event off of their website
because the truth is as small as a
minority that they are those are the
types of people that will show up and
throw a bricks at your windows and
Sydney Marga doesn't want to deal with
that you know what I mean yeah gay pride
parade doesn't want to deal with that so
they just they just caved they came to
the crazies and it's it's the sad thing
is I get messages every single day and
most even most LGBT people that are
creators either writers you know
bloggers the instagrams
but whatever youtubers we obviously 99%
of us well maybe not 99% 95% of us agree
with everything that I say and are just
terrified to talk about it they won't
because they're afraid to lose brand
deals there for you to you know upset a
younger you know section of their
audience but I'm not afraid of that like
are you there's a lot of young kids that
still follow me but those are also the
people that hate me the most and I think
it would be mental for me to continue to
try to win over people that already hate
me it's just not good for my mental
health and my well-being so I I want to
stand by my morals and I wanted to gain
a different audience of people that are
rational and and level-headed and can
have an actual conversation and and not
just scream Cerf into the you know
scream turf at me on Twitter and then
call me all these names without actually
having a solid argument and how is that
because it must be really really tough
because you know to come out
automatically you're saying I'm
different to the vast majority of people
right so that automatically makes you an
outsider that's what I imagine it's one
of the tough things about being gay LGBT
or the rest of it oh yeah you are now
within your own community you have now
become an outsider within there yes so
you have now effectively isolating
yourself from the people that you should
be affiliating with that must be
really tough isn't it it's it's not
tough on my ego because I know my own
worth but it's tough on my brand but it
is it's doing better now
like people are the people that are
watching my content now are like I don't
see like the comments that I get her
like why does everybody hate this girl
like she's literally saying nothing
wrong and I'm like thank God because
like I I knew that but well you see same
comments for six five six years since
2014 you know since I started posting
more T&Q content you know all the
negative comments they didn't get to me
as much as people would assume is I do
have a very strong sense of self but it
made me question myself and question my
not question my self-worth but question
my ability to communicate properly
because I'm like was I saying the wrong
thing and it's like no these people just
aren't understanding what I'm saying
I've said it a hundred different ways
and they just don't want to hear it and
that's on you know at that point I'm
like it's on them and I'm just not even
gonna try to change my wording anymore
like I've changed so much the way I've
changed so much of the way that I say
things over the years for the better I
do think that a lot of things that I
used to say back then weren't perfectly
worded
so I have learned a lot from that
community but at this point you know
when when the word woman is meaningless
I I can't get behind that
no it's talking about changing the the
words that you use do you feel having
had this D monetization episode where
essentially you're told there's
something wrong with your channel you're
not told what it is you you have to make
changes as best you can to try and
understand what it was that got you do
monetize in the first place are you now
kind of having to self censor yourself
going forward because just for people
who don't know you you know your channel
has over 600,000 subscribers so your
advertising revenue from that would be
quite significant so to lure think but
it's not yeah but but still I mean I
imagine I just basing it off on us and
you know having a hundred thousand
subscribers you know you can make a
living with I imagine oh you know having
six hundred thousand subscribers
so you're essentially having that
threatend over the fact that you've
started to talk about a particular issue
are you now feeling like you have to
censor yourself going forward in order
to protect your livelihood um I do but I
won't I'm gonna stand by my morals I've
always been that kind of person maybe
it's because I'm a New Yorker
but it it hit me that that's the first
time my channels ever been hit like that
I don't even think I had to me like
strikes on my channel ever you know what
I mean so it was just funny but it all
happened a month after I came out with
that video so it doesn't make me
question things but even even so it's
like I'm not even far right I'm just not
super progressive left anymore and I
still support the majority of left
you're not like like 50% like again
honest I think I'm like a libertarian is
what people call which is what the old
left is so I've always been left it's
just the left and moved even further so
I don't know what I don't know I part of
me just thinks that YouTube found like a
an easy way to target me maybe but at
the same time the more I talk about
things that I actually believe in and
I've always did that
but the controversial things that I
believe and will say that because I
never really touched on controversial
topics like this the more I'm getting
support monetarily from individual
viewers which ideally and hopefully
would would level out the Adsense
because I don't make much money on
Adsense anyway because most of my videos
are controversial and sexually explicit
not even socially explicit but sexual
topics so I don't really get ads on
those videos anyway but on the topics
that I don't talk about either of those
things I'm missing a few hundred bucks a
month so it did suck you know an area
what why do you think it is that we seem
to expect people who are in the LGBT
community or an ethnic minority to
somehow be left and if they expounds
views
say things that are not on the left we
see it is being problematic and want to
expel them why so I think it's just that
the group thinking hive mind mentality I
think that we assume well not we but
people on the left assume that anyone
that doesn't think like them is either
stupid or a grifter which I hate that
word cuz everyone's calling me that now
and it's like I wish I was because the
far far far right channels have not even
looked at me yet well welcome to the
club wait till that happens because then
they start attacking you as well we've
heard right we're left-wing grifters on
Monday and right-wing grifters and twos
there and then back to being far left on
Wednesday that's just that's just that's
just the turf that you're on now yeah
yeah exactly I did an interview with one
of my new friends David who is a trump
supporter more conservative I don't even
know if he considers himself a
Republican but he made and even if I
disagree with its politics has nothing
to do with that the point of the video
was stop bullying gave Trump supporters
stop bullying people that disagree with
you actually have a sit-down
conversation with them see where they're
coming from and you'll realize they're
not they're not all terrible people
mm-hmm and one of the things he said in
the video was brilliant and he said the
left the progressive left focuses so
much on diversity diversity of gender
sexual orientation skin color age
whatever and he's like but they all
think the same what about what why not
diversity of thought like why did we all
have to think the same and I was like
[ __ ] like smart dude I was like I ain't
gonna get that like I I obviously
thought of it but the way he worded it
was perfectly
yeah diversity of thought is what the
left unfortunately is is well what the
LGBT community is lacking you know it's
not just LGBT community so any minority
any money but it's like we're both
comedians in the comedy industry it's
the same you know people are
progressed and promoted and pushed for
who they are instead of what they what
they think of what their comedy is you
know yeah so I think it kind of happens
everywhere do you think there's a space
to be carved out in the middle because
I'm very much kind of in the
Center politically Francis as a kind of
rejected lefty you kind of odd starting
to realize that you are as well
and the question that people always and
like I get asked like why I'm
conservative whole time and I keep
having to say that I'm not actually
conservative like I did an interview
with somebody that a few weeks ago and
that was their opening question and
people assume all the time that if
you're not [ __ ] that far left you're
on the other side do you think there's a
space to be just carved out somewhere in
the middle for like sensible people who
you know they have their own views on
things but they still don't reject
science completely and they don't you
know they don't go down the crazy rabbit
holes of the far right or the far left
yeah I think there's more I think
luckily because of people like Dave
Rubin and and Blair at just anybody on
the LGBT community that isn't left that
isn't super left they don't even have to
be conservative because neither of them
are like truly conservative it's carving
out space for the rest of us to be like
wait I can I cannot be like super
low-key and progressive me and Lefty and
believe in 87 genders I think just
speaking about it helps and I think more
P I got more comments and more likes on
my videos than ever before look so I
think people were afraid to talk about
it until somebody else started talking
about it which was the same for me and
until people like Blair and and and Dave
Rubin and you know even buck angel who's
not conservative he's he's a lefty but
he's he's very aware of science he's a
trans guy and you know Pesta one of the
first transsexual porn stars and he's
just a sweetheart well for female spaces
you know because you know even trans man
that are female experience different
things to sis man yeah but he's just
awesome and luckily the the rise in
popularity of those people gave way for
people like myself to speak more openly
about what they believe you know and
when do you think because you look at a
lot of the media and well I can't really
speak about the media in the UK which is
very very left dominated it's very very
progressive the liberal arts very very
progressive as well Wendy
think our type of voices are going to
become more acceptable in the mainstream
do you think that's going to happen
sooner rather than later would you you
just see this situation getting worse
which is what I think is gonna happen
sadly you're just a depressive I think
either way it's job security for us
because we have more to talk about so I
don't know I think I I mean I hope that
people start to come to their senses
more and stop denying science and I
think people are getting fed up with the
crazy far-left which is why the rate of
acceptance is down for us so I think
people are realizing that they need to
be more vocal and it's happening just at
a very slow rate because people are
still very scared they're still really
afraid oh and why do you think they're
afraid is it because you know people
stand a very real chance of losing
livelihoods jobs absolutely oh
absolutely
they've told me and there's old there's
also articles written about it that cuz
you get to remember a lot of LGBT people
already work in the arts feel art and
arts and humanities fields that tend to
be more progressive you know named when
how many leg gay men accountants to you
know like obviously there's a lot but in
general like I used to work in
advertising like half of the company was
LGBT I don't know why we flux fluctuate
that way we just we flock to it I mean
we just do maybe because it's good to
express ourselves or who the hell knows
but LGBTQ people tend to gravitate more
towards the arts creative fields of
various fields and that's that's where
the unfortunate not unfortunately that's
where the most progressive minds tend to
be so when you're more you know center
or right it's I would imagine it's it's
super difficult to to come out like my
the kid David he's like I thought I've
had nothing he's like I came out his
conservative and I got nothing but hate
from the left and nothing but love from
the right he's like they don't care I'm
gay they do not care if I'm gay
they don't care if I want to get married
they just they it's like for them it's
more I think more people now a
conservative economically more than
conservative socially and I think people
get that mixed up as well yeah there is
a big difference that's interesting
because it depends what you mean by it
for example in the UK a lot of people
actually being revealed is socially
conservative but our conversation is
very different to yours so acceptance of
you know gay people is completely
universal I would say but we won't talk
about something like immigration that
you know reluctance or resistance to
mass immigration would be a conservative
issue that a lot of people hold disagree
yeah but anyway look thanks very much
for coming on it's good to know your
channel has been Ramana ties I have a
sneaking suspicion that you're gonna
you're gonna end up back back in that
position at some point if you continue
but then you know that's all of us right
now isn't that with with the way that
things are going the last question we
always ask Ariel is what's the one thing
that no one is talking about that we
should be talking about as a society I
think I'm gonna stick it with with the
lesbian issues I think more people need
to listen to issues that affect females
and stop trying to be super woke about
gender politics at the moment nicely
listened to why a lot of females are
rejecting it I would listen to women
that's never gonna catch on certainly
not in Russian I'm from Russia so ya
know where I'm from for sure but we'll
see if we can make it catch on here in
the West I really I will thank you so
much if people want to follow your work
where do they go for that they could
just search my name on any other
platforms and I'll come up I think well
thanks for coming to so much take care
we'll see you again thanks for watching
guys as always subscribe to the youtube
channel click the bell button next to
subscribe button so you get notified
when a video comes out and follow us on
all the social media at trigger pod and
also leave us a nice review on iTunes
and spread the word